a drone airfield in Switzerland
researchers are testing a cargo drone
for the redline project similar models
could be used one day to transport
medicine in Africa you know Africa will
be able to transport supplies from one
village to the next or from the regional
hospital to a village this is not about
delivering a package to somebody's house
but rather to the town square
or a landing strip there will be drones
that deliver medicine they might be
smaller and be able to take off
vertically and there will be drones that
look more like classic aircraft the
drone flies completely autonomously and
it can fly up to 70 kilometers on a
single battery charge
[Music]
Africa's road network can be poor or
even non-existent for cargo drones
that's not a problem what normally would
take hours or days by Road can be flown
in needing only a fraction of that time
journalist Jonathan LED guard initiated
the red line project and currently leads
it he wants to transform the continents
transport infrastructure just for
example eastern Congo 7 million people
one Road one Road 7 million people now
you do not have to be a macro account
economists or a clinical health
specialist to realize that if you can
have a craft which can fly across the
jungle over the lake through the
mountain then then that's going to
provide better health outcomes better
economic
and what have the test determined could
this vertical take-off drone be a viable
candidate for the Africa project Mezen
sadly the mid-july stick we're very
happy with his performance and this
drone is especially robust compared to
other vertical take-off drones if all
goes well the project will be launched
in Rwanda in 2017